So, how long you been a Muslim?
>> For 5 years.
>> Five. Five years.
>> Yeah, bro.
>> Okay. Allah's not God, man. What you got
to say about that?
>> All I got to say is the Holy Trinity is
from Hakkate, bro. You can look up a
What does that do? What does that
do? A lot. It's got to do with me
proving to you that Allah is God because
your God is false.
>> Okay. So, you could do that right.
First, you got to prove to me that Allah
is truly God. And then we and then you
could prove the Trinity.
>> All right. Give me one second. Let me go
get my Let me go get my Quran, bro.
>> All right. Go get that Quran. You say
you say that Muhammad the wrote these
down or it's not it's his words.
>> I never said Muhammad wrote this down.
>> I'm asking you.
>> I I I I don't know. I honestly don't
know. I just know that these are these
are these are words of man, not God. I
know that.
>> Oh, really? Okay. So, let's see.
>> Mhm.
>> 53. Chapter 53.
>> It's known
>> verse 2 and 4.
>> Chapter 53.
>> And yeah, chapter 53. Go to chapter 53.
>> What it say, big dog? says chapter uh
verse two, "Your fellow man is neither
misguided nor a stray, nor does he speak
of his own whims. It is only a
revelation sent down to him. He has been
taught by the one mighty angel of mighty
power, which is the Holy Spirit."
>> Does it say which is the Holy Spirit?
>> Yeah. And I got another one for you.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Just really quick cuz
you I'm going to trust you're not going
to lie to me, right?
>> And then you got 16102.
>> Slow down. Slow down.
>> I'm not lying to you.
>> That verse right there, did it say which
is the Holy Spirit? said the mighty
power.
>> Did it say which is the Holy Spirit?
>> No, it does not. But I'll show you that
another verse that says it it is.
>> I got you. So So just just for this just
for us brothers, just for our growth and
our and and even the listeners,
>> can we agree that we will not add or
take away from the Quran verses or the
Bible verses. We're only going to say
what's there. Is that fair,
>> bro? What you say is in the Bible is not
written or Jesus never even saw that
stuff.
>> You can have that, brother. That's fine.
You can have that opinion. I'm trying
I'm trying to have a common ground with
you.
>> I'm trying to have a common ground with
>> Can we Can you and I agree as men that
in in this conversation, we're only
going to say what the Bible says or what
the Quran says. We're not going to add
to the verses. Can we agree with that?
>> Yeah, bro. I don't I'm not adding
nothing. It's right here, bro.
>> Okay, cool. So, can I show
>> is not is not a is not is it is Titus a
prophet?
>> Can I show you something? No.
>> I want to know if Titus is Titus a
>> has nothing to do what we're talking
about. Stop.
>> Yeah, it does. You said that he said
>> this is not going to last long, bro.
This ain't going to last long.
>> Come on. All right, we're good. Come on.
>> Okay. Do you So So obviously you believe
that Allah is God, right?
>> Oh, I know it is. I know he is. So yeah.
>> Okay. So he doesn't have a God above
him. Is that right?
>> No, he doesn't. There's no God above
Allah.
>> All right. That's That's cool. I
understand that. I understand that. And
and from what your and from your belief,
I just want to make sure cuz I don't
want to misrepresent you. You believe
that the Quran is word for word the word
of Allah, right? Every single word he
spoke is is from Allah verbatim. He's
the one speaking.
>> Preserved. Yes.
>> Okay. So he Allah is the speaker of the
Quran. Is that right? Nobody else?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> All right. Cool. All right. So I need
your I need to get your understanding of
this real quick, my brother.
>> Yeah, I understand.
>> So I'm I'mma share I'mma show a verse on
the screen.
>> All right. Cool. And then read the next
one cuz I already know you're going to
>> Of course. I'm going to read in context,
bro. I'm I'm always read in context,
man. Always. Okay. I I've already I
already know all your tricks, bro. Don't
worry about it.
>> All right. I'mma read the next one.
Okay. So, uh I'm gonna try to try to Oh,
okay. Cool. Look at that. Can you see
the screen?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Awesome. All right. So, this verse
says, this is chapter 19 verse 63.
>> Okay.
>> It says, "That is paradise,
which we shall give as an inheritance to
those of our servants who are
God-fearing." Who's speaking there?
That's all. law, right?
>> Yeah, it's a law.
>> Okay. So, Allah says that he's going to
be the one giving paradise.
>> Can I can I tell you something? We, us,
>> who? That's all attributes to Almighty
God. Correct.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Yeah. Right. Does Does God not speak
like that?
>> Sometimes it is we.
>> No, it's not. It's always Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. It's always got you. No
worries. Okay.
>> We us who
>> I got you. So, this is Allah speaking.
He says, "We shall give as an
inheritance." I'm sorry. Paradise is
what he we will give as an inheritance
to those of our servants who are
God-fearing. Okay. Now, I'm going to
bring up the next verse. I'm going to
bring up the next verse.
>> I'm going to read you Let me read you
the Let me read you the verse out of the
clear Quran. So, it says, "That is
paradise, which we will grant to whoever
is devout among our servants."
>> That don't change anything. I
>> You're on Quran X. I know. Yeah, but
you're on Quran. You should just be on
quran.com.
>> It doesn't matter. I don't know why. I'm
just using a track.
>> It It actually does cuz it has taps in
it as well. So,
>> well, so does this. You see this? It
says tapsier here. I can pull up the
tops if I want.
>> Okay. But I don't I don't trust
>> But we don't need tops, right? We need
We got the Quran. The Quran is clear
enough.
>> So, you want to pull up 16102.
>> Hold on a second. We're going verse by
verse. I need you to be hyperfocused, as
focused as you can.
>> All right. Yes, sir.
>> So, now watch this. So, you said that
the Wii is Allah. All right. Cool. Then
Allah continues and he says, "We come
not down save at the command of your
Lord. To him belongs all that is before
us and all that is behind us and all
between that." So it Allah says, "We
come not down except at the command of
your Lord." Who's commanding Allah to
come down?
>> This is Can you see this?
>> No, I can't see that. I can only see the
the Quran. In my in my Quran,
>> in my Quran, this is the Gabriel's
response to the prophet, right?
>> It doesn't say that. It doesn't say
Gabriel,
>> but it says it in mine. So, that's what
I'm telling you.
>> I'm sorry. Is it is yours in
parenthesis?
>> Let's see. 575.
>> Real quick. Third. Is yours in
parenthesis?
>> No, it's not.
>> Okay, good. So, if it's not in
parenthesis, let's read what the actual
text says, which it says we, as you said
before, the Wii is Allah. That's always
Allah. We come not down except at the
commandment of your Lord. So somebody's
commanding Allah to go down and Allah
saying to him belongs all that is before
us and all that's behind us and all that
between that. So who commanded Allah to
come down?
>> All right. So I'm going to give you the
context. It says this passage is a
response to the prophet's request to be
visited by the by Gabriel more often.
That's what's going on.
>> Where in my Quran? Yeah. Wait, where in
the cor what where in the where in the
verse does it say that? That's what I'm
asking.
>> It's not in the verse, bro. It's in the
footnote. It's in the footnotes, sir.
>> Yeah, that's exactly. You don't use
footnotes in your Bible,
>> man. So So footnote over the over the
Quran, huh,
>> bro? I'm trying to tell you it's the
footnotes explain the Quran even better.
>> The whole I I got you. The footnotes.
You know what? Somebody Somebody else
I got you. Somebody Somebody else
that the footnotes were better than the
Quran. Somebody else down y'all.
Somebody somebody else that we
>> somebody that was really close. He he he
believed footnotes were also better than
the Quran. Who is that?
>> So you So you like to read hadith and
taps but you but you but then you to
reject it when someone tells you about
it.
>> Hold on. Aren't I reading the Quran?
>> Yeah but you also but you also
>> So in the Quran in the Quran Allah is
speaking. Correct.
>> Where was the deflection?
>> You told me that every word in the Quran
is Allah speaking. Not Gabriel.
>> Yes. And I gave you the whole context
behind it. The passage is a response to
the prophet's request by Gabriel.
>> Who's responding to him?
>> Allah is responding to the prophet.
>> Good. So Allah's telling Muhammad, "Hey,
Muhammad, we don't come down except at
the commandment of your Lord." Who
command? Who's the Lord of Allah that
commands him to come down?
>> There is no Lord of Allah, bro. I'm I'm
trying to tell you
>> responded Allah responded with this
verse because the prophet requested to
be visited by Gabriel more often.
>> So Allah when Muhammad asked please
Allah can you please send Gabriel to
come more often. Allah responded to
Muhammad and said hey Muhammad we don't
come down. Hold on hold on. Muhammad
respon I mean Allah responds and says
hey Muhammad
>> we don't come down except at the
commandment of your lord and to him
belongs everything that is before us
after us between us so Allah tells
Muhammad hey man we don't come down
except at the command of your lord so
Allah tells Muhammad that he gets
commandments from the lord of Muhammad
so who is that
>> the lord of Muhammad is a law bro
>> no it ain't
>> you don't Yeah it is it definitely is
>> yeah And that's your lord too, bro. So,
>> well, it seems to me that Allah has a
lord that that he receives commands
from.
>> Like I said, you should look up Hakate
the triune goddess, bro. That's what I
ain't looking at.
I'm looking up all based off of I told
you is Hakate the Lord of Allah.
>> Hakate is your lord, bro.
>> Oh, okay. So, and and Allah's lord,
right?
>> Triune goddess, bro.
>> Hakate is my lord and your hidden in the
in the in this in the in the crone, bro.
That's what the father, the son, and the
holy spirit are based off of. Akante is
my Lord and Allah's Lord. Huh?
>> Go go go go go go up go look it up, bro.
>> Hey man, we don't we don't come up by
the by the commandment of
>> this verse. I just told you. I'm not
laughing, bro.
>> Oh, you should, man. We got to be
lighting up anyway. Not funny at all.
>> All right. You know what? Okay. You know
what? This might not This might not bro
cuz this doesn't tell us. I'm going to
show you the next verse cuz this one
doesn't tell us who the Lord of Allah
necessarily is. Who's receiving command?
>> There is no Lord of Allah. Well, I mean
it is. It says that he is the Lord.
Allah is the only Lord, bro.
>> Then why is he receiving commands?
>> It's a third person. You don't think God
talks in the third person?
>> Wait, you told me that the Wii is Allah
himself.
>> Exactly. We
>> Okay. So, yeah, he's talking in the
third person about himself, right?
>> And our angels, bro. That's what he's
talking about, bro. We are in a
messenger angel. Gabriel is the
messenger angel, bro. He's the Holy
Spirit. So, to be clear, 161, I want to
understand you. I want to understand
you. So when you're now what you're
saying is is that when it says we that's
Allah and the angel
>> bro
>> we and our angels bro as in him and his
angels he gives his angels task bro
>> it doesn't say who is task to bring out
the revelation
>> it says we're receiving the task
>> hey uh God logic who in your Bible who
is tasked to give down
>> why do you keep going to my Bible my
Bible's not going to help you
>> because I'm asking you it's the Holy
Spirit
>> I know but I need you to stay focused my
Bible is not helping you. You need to
explain your verses without my Bible cuz
they're not connected.
>> The Bible is out of there, bro. I got
also you also said, but then you look at
John 2:4, he talked back to his mom.
That's a sin, right?
>> Let me let me ask.
>> Yeah, exactly, bro. Yeah, exactly. Yeah,
>> cuz we need to find out who the God of
Allah is, man.
>> There is no God of Allah, brother.
>> Let's find out.
>> It says mine right here. We only descend
by the command of your Lord. To him
belongs whatever we
>> is before us. Allah, bro. It's a third
person, bro.
>> So, the Wii only comes down who's Allah
only comes down at the commandment of
your Lord. Who's giving Allah commands?
>> It's in the third person context, bro.
You understand that, right? You know how
people like, oh, you know how you talk
in the third person?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I got you.
>> You understand, right?
>> I got you. I got you. I got you. All
right. So, I need I need to understand
in the same chapter.
>> Got another verse. 1934.
>> Same chapter. This is 1934. It says that
is Jesus son of Mary in word of truth
concerning which they are doubting.
Who's speaking here?
>> That is the law.
>> So Allah speaking about Jesus.
>> Yes. And mine says that is Jesus son of
Mary. This is a word of truth
>> about which they dispute. It is not for
and then 35. It is not for God to take a
son.
>> Wait wait wait wait wait.
Slow down. Go.
>> So Allah Allah speaking Allah speaking.
Okay. Then we go to the next verse. When
Allah speaks about stories, he it's from
it's from his perspective.
>> I got you. So Allah continues and he
says in the next verse, he says, "It is
not for God. It's not for Allah to take
a son unto him." Allah still speaking,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So Allah says, "It's not for God
to take a son unto him. Glory be to him.
When he decrees a thing, he but says to
it be and it is." Okay.
>> Yes. Exactly. So all Isaac about God.
Just like Isaac, bro. I got you. Now,
let's see what else Allah says. So,
Allah continues to say, he says, "Surely
God is my Lord." Uh
>> oh. And your Lord.
>> Let me see. No, look. Look. 36. Jesus
also declared, "Surely no, it doesn't
say Jesus." God is my Lord. And your
Lord,
>> my brother.
Does the text say Jesus?
>> Huh?
>> Bro, come on, bro.
>> Does it say Jesus?
>> Look, it's in parenthesis, bro.
>> So, if it's in parenthesis, is it in the
text? It's to It's to be clarified,
brother.
>> Be honest with you. That's why I have to
clear brother. We got We got 3,200
people watching here on YouTube right
here, bro.
>> We have 3,200 people watching here on
YouTube. Be honest.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm tell are the So, tell the
truth.
>> Are the parenthesis part of the text,
brother? Obviously not.
>> Okay. Obviously not. So, it doesn't say
anything about Jesus. The speaker is
still Allah. The speaker is still
>> Yes, it he is speaking the words of
Jesus.
>> Where does it say that? Where does it
say? Where does it say that Allah is
quoting Jesus?
>> Right there, bro.
>> Show me. Show me. I'm I'm waiting. Show
me where it says Allah's quoting Jesus.
Show me the verse.
>> Give me a minute, bro. It's right there,
bro.
>> Show me the verse. Show me where it says
Allah's
>> What do you mean, bro? It says Jesus
also declared, "Surely God is my work."
You already said that. That's in
parenthesis, right?
>> Bro, there's so many freaking
parentheses in the Bible. So, why are
you tripping?
>> Hey, man. I want to say thank you for
coming.
>> You're You're being hyp you're being
hypocritical.
>> Thank you for coming. Get off my stage.
You're done. Appreciate you. Appreciate
you, big dog. Ah, that was fun. That was
fun. That was a fun one. I couldn't wait
to use that. Y'all see that? Did y'all
peep that? Am I Arabic speakers in the
chat? You guys confirm for me. Is this
what it says on the text? Does it say
exactly what I have on the screen? The
speaker never changes. The speaker never
changes. Now what happens is that you
have some translations that lie in order
to put a band-aid on the text because
they they wish Allah why Allah why did
you have to say this? Why? Now we got to
throw in our commentaries to save you.
It doesn't say Jesus is speaking here.
The speaker is Allah. My Arabic
speakers, Muslims, Christians, it
doesn't matter what you are. Y'all can
affirm for me the speaker is Allah. It
never changes. Allah is the one speaking
about Jesus. That is Jesus, son of Mary,
and word of truth concerning which they
are doubting. He's not quoting him. Now,
watch this. Watch what happens when
Allah does quote Jesus. What happens?
Let's see what happens when he quotes
Jesus. Watch what it says. Watch what it
says. Here it is. Is this right here? It
is. He said, it ain't in parentheses.
You ain't got to fit that in the text.
It's part of the original Arabic. It
says he said. Now we see when Allah is
quoting Jesus. He said, "Lo, I am God's
servant. God has given me the book and
made me the prophet." Next verse.
Blessed he blessed he has made me
wherever I may be. And he has adjoined
me to pray and to give alms so long as I
live. Jesus is still talking. And
likewise to cherish my mother. He has
not made me arrogant, unprosperous.
Peace be upon me the day that I was
born, the day I die, and the day I am
raised alive. Then Allah begins to speak
again. That is Jesus son of Mary in word
of truth concerning which they are
doubting. Allah is recounting what Jesus
said to Muhammad revealing revealing
this to him. So Allah says that was
Jesus son of Mary. Allah continues to
speak. It is not for God to take a son
unto him. [clears throat] Glory be to
him. When he decrees a thing he says to
it be and it is. And then Allah
continues to say, "Surely
God is my Lord. Allah is my Lord and
your Lord. So serve you him. This is a
straight path." What? So Allah is the
Lord of Allah. Allah has a god. Allah
ain't really God. Damn, man. Allah has
an Allah. Allah got an Allah. Allah. Do
Do Allah got a Allah? Do Allah got an
Allah? What's one plus one? Allah got an
Allah. Goodness gracious. The clear
Quran. The clear Quran. Allah got Allah.
The clear Quran. Amazing. Now, if Allah
was a trinity, this would make sense. It
would make sense that Allah would humble
himself to another person within the
Godhead and submit to him with no
problem without ceasing to be God
himself. But unfortunately, Allah is a
unitarian
uh lad. He's a he's a unitarian young
lad. So there's somebody outside of
Allah that's Allah.